[Music]
venom venomous these words may make you
think of a thick fluid milked from the
fangs of a dangerous snake but the
latest venom science is turning to new
sources of venom centipedes assassin
bugs stealthy cone snails with the rise
of tools that let scientists explore all
the proteins peptides and small
molecules that make up venom scientists
have been able to deconstruct the potent
toxic cocktails made by the world's
tiniest mixologists
some of those include rare animals that
aren't easy to raise in the lab most
venomous animals aren't actually that
rare there are more than 220,000 species
that brew up their own toxic mixes from
all branches of the family tree for a
long time researchers focused on only a
small set of venomous animals spiders
snakes scorpions and some cone snails
looking for new therapeutics and for
clues to how venom victim pairs evolved
how does venom change an animal's
behavior does the killer juice make you
less afraid of intimidating beasties and
why does some animals like the assassin
bug evolve two Venom's one for defending
itself and one for killing its prey the
arms race between predator and resistant
prey has led to complex Venom's that are
incredibly precise in their targeting
fast-acting and potent all useful
characteristics for medicines the toxins
and Venom's tend to either attack the
nervous system paralyzing muscles lungs
sometimes blinding their prey or they
disrupt blood coagulation causing blood
to coagulate quickly or preventing
coagulation either can be deadly
such Venom's have helped scientists
understand these systems themselves a
classic example using pufferfish venom
to find a channel important to nerve
signaling the targeting ability of these
Venom's and their strong effects on the
body have also led to six venom base
trucks that have already been approved
including a drug for diabetes from the
venom of the Gila monster
painkiller derive from the venom of the
so called magical cone snail now
scientists are looking to these new
sources of venom like the sea anenome to
treat an autoimmune disease and the
Deathstalker scorpion for an entirely
different use imaging brain tumors
during surgery and someday scientists
might just catch up with these ancient
chemists but don't count on it
[Music]
you
[Music]